the Bank of England is issuing new
banknotes beginning with a five-pound
note and they're made of plastic and
they've been all sorts of advertisements
but you can't break them I felt
immediately challenged and I had the
idea if we froze it with liquid nitrogen
the strands of the polymer would be
frozen rigid and you may be able to
break it hitting it with a hammer so I
gave Neal several of my own five-pound
notes you can't spend university money
on things like this and he had great
pleasure trying to break the professor's
bank notes and it worked he managed the
flash one but it took several attempts
you had to get the orientation just
right and hit it just in the right way
and then it broke into two or three
pieces unfortunately he lost one of the
pieces that I couldn't glue it together
and spend the note so it's a souvenir
incidentally it's not illegal to break
the notes though it's illegal to draw
pictures on Her Majesty's face but Neal
felt that this wasn't really quite
exciting enough so he decided to put
this in his special supply of fuming
nitric acid it's a bit old so it's gone
Brown so it may be even better fuming
nitric acid and there are several
thoughts and I'm not sure what Neal's
Pike was particularly that essentially
is a mixture of pure nitric acid or
nearly pure nitric acid with n2o4
dinitrogen tetroxide added to it and
n2o4 itself can dissociate into no.2 so
it's quite a which is green or perhaps I
should say Wizards brew in case of meal
it is well known as being a very
powerful cleaning agent if you can't get
muck off your glassware the last resort
is fuming nitric acid Neil's hypothesis
was that he could completely dissolve it
it would just disappear and he could
have a solution of a five-pound note
what happened was actually much more
exciting but when he put it in the
Queen's space quickly faded when he took
it out there was some of the writing and
stuff still left
[Music]
the teachers brushed off quite easily
and what he was left with so all our
surprise was a completely transparent
piece of plastic exactly the same size
but he started with I gave this sample
to one of my students who ran an
infrared spectrum and showed that it was
polypropylene this is the plastic made
from protein when it says on the
Internet these are made from
polypropylene they're right it's really
fun I now show this to people and say
what you think it is and they had no
idea you can see that we do the proper
experiments in the sense that we had the
control I insisted that they also used
one of the old paper notes the Queen
didn't fade as much on the paper notes
but when they taken it out and drive it
it was interesting that the notes had
gained really quite a lot of weight and
this was absolutely consistent with my
idea that the fuming nitric acid might
nitrate the cellulose of the paper this
is adding no.2 groups to the paper and
nitrated paper burns very much better
than the ordinary paper
[Music]
it's used by magicians and conjurors and
it's the basis in fact of guncotton
which is used as an explosive
it went with a real Bush and what was
particularly interesting is that it
burns without any ash at all it just
disappeared and the reason for this is
that with the no.2 groups you have
enough oxygen in the notes to make it
burn to completion so we have a really
nice farewell for the old paper
banknotes it just disappears into thin
air I must stress that we've done this
in the instance of science and because
we think it's important and interesting
experiment but on the other hand we are
destroying banknotes and so we feel that
it's only right that we've given them
equal amounts of money to charity to
show that we don't really want to
destroy my name just for the sake of it
I should say to you that if you want to
repeat these experiments that probably
cheaper way from doing it and using
banknotes